on this episode we're going to rescue
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is
because Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 257 of the
askgaryvee show and i've got to say this
and a lot of you watch or listen to the
show know and I just don't really
consume a lot of content I produce a
shitload of content and then I watch how
people engage with it
but I'm very fired up to have our guests
today because really besides watching
New York Jets
I think his television show is one of
the few things I've consumed in the last
three years and I go on binges right
because I play it back to back to back
to back I remember I was in Canada once
it was canon once I stayed up from like
midnight to 4:00 in the morning back to
back to back on who knows what channel
they are John I'm really excited you're
here great to be here yes watch why
don't you tell the Vayner nation who you
are and a little bit about your career
and then we'll answer some questions and
I'm just I'm really excited you're here
good to be here you know looking at your
background you don't have a similar
background so you know I didn't start in
the wine business tarted a restaurant
business yes and I started as a
bartender yeah I'm a general manager yes
Hotel Manager resort food and beverage
director resort general manager did
pretty much everything in the industry
that I could and I've been giving
speeches the nightclub and bar
convention and all over the world did
you have that kind of personality I do
and I'm and I give very good speeches I
didn't pay well for yeah so I was giving
a speech at the convention somebody
comes up to me one day and says John you
should be on TV so I wrote up a little
piece called on the rocks I went to a
friend of mine who ran paramount
television yes sat down in the office
and he looks at me goes John you will
never be on television you're too old
you're not good-looking enough yes he
goes forget it
so I walked out of that office with the
vendetta yeah I know there I shot my own
sizzle reel no you did not I did produce
my own write-up of the show on my own
brought to sizzle reel to four different
production companies within five days
Garry I had four offers the network
picked up the show four days after I
signed with a network production company
and in less than a year from that guy
saying to me we'll never be anything
else
the series premiered what's that guy's
name a David goldsmith hey David
goldsmith you [ __ ] lost this one
completely - god I must have you a good
guy but I did send them a dozen black
roses I love it you know this is just a
button up the hallways you probably for
the couple you know we have a lot of you
know people who might have not got
what's the show like you know how many
seasons what network shorts on Spike
we just finished which is going to be
rebranded right did January 8th spike
its rebranded as the paramount networks
right which were really excited about
you're in an ogre yeah and I started to
show six years ago we've done a hundred
and forty seven episodes I just signed
for twenty more and we're getting into
the record category and business
transformation shows almost nobody's
cross 150 but Kitchen Nightmares never
crossed 100 so you know none of these
shows really make it past 100 episodes
so now last season about 90 million
Americans watched it it's now on five
thousand channels and five continents
and six languages and if you think it's
intense to watch me in English you
should see me in Peruvian it's not
nothing
how many of you have seen the show yeah
dunk
they don't play this in Sweden no race
president nohrin Norway we are going to
Norway I do not speak no we don't
believe in English ignoring that
translate jumper that Johnson before we
get into some Q&A you know the thing
that stood out for me and probably why I
so sated with it besides the fact that
you know where we've got a Type A
personalities and thing forget about the
personality stick style vibe DNA take
that completely over here your practical
yeah you're an operator and it's real
I'm aware I like because I am only you
know I think a lot of times people can
get caught up in my sizzle but it's the
steak that I'm most proud of I'm an
operator like I think of it as a
business like I can't not that I can't
leave you can always lose but I say my
little narrow lane I know what I know
and when I watched it even with editing
for television like [ __ ] that's right
yeah he's right like and you do a lot of
EQ stuff you're like you know I've 800
people that work for me what probably
also attracted me and I'm like I like
this guy and whenever we first connected
on Twitter I'm like yeah let's I want to
get to know this dude
is you operate it's about margins and
it's about shelf play almost enough that
I grew up in the liquor business right
and all that stuff but it was also like
oh that manager is insecure so you're
finished so that pertinent to me the
thing I'm most proud of is the content
that I produce at scale
the reason I'm excited at people when
they watch it is i if they can get over
certain things with themselves with me
even my style if they will win if they
listen to win yes and I believe that
your show and you are powerful for that
because I do believe when I watch it as
a person that will always win in
business if if they listen they will win
well you know what I've learned is every
failing business as a failing owner Gary
it's only the owner involved so so if
they have a failing owner after 147 bar
rescues you know guys like you and I
were and everything about success yeah
what do you do to be successful the
black success me planks a successful
after 147 bar rescues Gary I've seen a
depth of failure nobody seen yeah how
many real quick iPod Justin's with you
how many so I just did this show also
for Apple playing with the apps where
I'm helping these app developers right I
was blown away by how much I gave a [ __ ]
like I didn't like it I didn't like when
I was mentoring them like this sucks
like I really want them to win and
they're not lit not that they weren't
listening actually that's not true
it was more just like I wanted them to
win is it how long do you when you shoot
an episode like how long are you in
there for days like when you hear you've
done six seasons right when you hear
through the grapevine a random email
just when you hear when you're a teen
years when you hear like Oh taco
Johnnie's became hotrod Johnny's and now
it's failed hurt or you're like a
meritocracy and like you're okay you are
normal again and I'm here I get it I
know you do that houses are on I'm the
last chance to have enough money for we
good there's an independent website that
tracks my success is that right it's
called bar rescue updates and it was
started to assassinate me but now
they're pretty honest they're pretty
straight about it they have a shame we
believe this started to like gradual it
was because I know I watched it when it
wasn't first on it now it's now it's
they're very fair they have an
advertiser base before and after you
don't reviews
right so they have new racking it a 75
to 80% success factor that's amazing
considering considering look you're at a
hundred percent success factor for a guy
like me just so you know you're at 100%
it's just basic it's the base it's basic
to us because we've known in our lives
you're at a hundred percent success rate
to me your advice is always right you're
just at the mercy of Ric yes
and what happens with these people is
they've made decisions that way for a
long long time and they get stuck in
this room is more of them
tasted what it should look like and had
the ability to stay the course it's
phenomenal
but why is that and that's worth picking
apart for describe the two most powerful
motivators we have is fear yes and pride
yes so let's say you have a failing bar
I'll start to play with pride because I
got to change you to change this big
hundred percent I'm gonna work pride how
would you feel for successful how do you
imagine it okay that doesn't work now
fear what happens when you lose your
[ __ ] house yeah you're losing look at
this picture of your head what happens
when you can't touch it I got to make
them terrified to change you guys do you
got in real life versus TV life which I
think you've got a real show but I
assume and tell me if I'm wrong a lot of
bars fail because a lot of times the
owner like likes to drink yes cliche
life you're in the drug coming a
pharmacist I think it makes no sense why
you guys tried it right you guys try it
right buddy right you guys try to filter
out that one variable right we do you
know that would make sense that's just
smart what I want to do is I want I want
to tell stories that people want to hear
family drama
yeah partnership yeah Miz you know it's
a real answer yeah real and it's very
Shakespearean guy in trouble resists
change transforms himself redeems
themself and in it's really very
Shakespearean if you think about are you
kidding and it's [ __ ] it's great TV
right like you pick up the tile and
there's [ __ ] worms everywhere and if
I like how you share slugs everywhere
what the [ __ ] I want to tell you story
I've never told before yeah so guys were
exclusives here on episode 257 yes Karen
you should go ahead the fourth episode
of bar rescue was shut down by the
network really and it was shut down by
the network because I was doing my thing
and a network executive came on set and
tried to fake something and now
ask your Shan I told him to go [ __ ]
himself 100% made him sitting to
McDonald yt3 our time
d-roc well I just play your one workout
I could see why you do that a [ __ ] he
tries to tell me what to do
so finishing the story so they shut down
in production now the senior VP of the
network flies into Chicago
yes communities walking me around the
block I've got understand you can't tell
the vice president of the network to go
[ __ ] himself
this can't do that so I took control of
the show they never did it again and
I've told me go [ __ ] themselves now
about four or five other times now
they're wonderful but what happens is
and I'm not putting them down at all
right I know we listen they have you in
yours to know what's going to happen
before it happens you can't and I won't
do that I can tell there's a push and
pull that's constantly going on between
us to protect that reality and I'm
guessing you can relate to it what I
wasn't for the reality wouldn't lasted
this long
a hundred percent and and and I do think
you know I wouldn't have you sitting
here I'm stunned that you guys that
story makes a ton of sense to me
because being empathetic to that
universe you guys have been able to pull
it off it's really cool I'm glad you're
here let's everyone let's get some
questions going before I go Andy's gonna
get some questions we're going to answer
some of them but before we do that
where'd you grow up
Great Neck Long Island and so are from
here please jump please tell me your
Jets fan I am a Jets fan tell us who
don't belong right I will get crazy on
you right on my age back to the Joe
Namath well I get a dad's man so so how
old were you in nineteen January 12 1969
in 1969 I was angry twelve seventeen so
you really were in a prime year when
they want a sort of thing were you
walking me I remember man I'm on my boy
I'm sure I remembered big were you
Knicks fan so I was in X fan as well
know these days of the butcher well I
even you are a Mets fan too and oh yeah
a Mets fan because I lived on Long
Island Long Island Railroad to show said
we oughta watch Kingman blast that would
stage normally or minutes 69 70 you
literally won an NBA NFL and World
Series champion Rick you were the king
of the world
I thought so yeah how do you not be a
Jets fan after going through that at 17
years you're Jeff Manfred I mean is like
the regular times a thousand and cool so
well that's the point
McGregor is pretty cool who's that you
sure because this is elegant battling
anymore Nick
yeah bro what's up man what part of
Jersey are you from
why would Wildwood I spent a summer
there once for five minutes a lot of
people did there you go I figure you
didn't know it from where you're from
say Little John yeah I'm doing John I
saw you over there yep what's your
question my pride
um just started a new restaurant and
it's funny you have him on next
obviously know that yes but uh the best
way to get it out there without spending
a fortune where where is it before John
asks his questions it's in whywould
which is a resort town
we got a few months to do we do um
you opened on I had a restaurant oh yeah
yeah and I had a restaurant before with
a partner I walked away from that with
nothing throw everything against the
wall I know it'll stick I got faith in
the risk but I need to get it out there
okay in your business let me get to the
point for your business you got to pull
the I then pull the body then pull their
wallet you don't get the wallet until
you have the I in the body first so you
got to look at the exterior the front of
your business and make sure you're
drawing attention just off the top of my
head what's your fit what does this food
item you're known for actually burgers
gourmet burgers so you putting out
degress burgers in the world I would
create eight or ten picket signs wooden
poles with cardboard signs say world's
best hamburgers price is unfair to
competition buns softest in town best
burger or it's free I would positive
pick it in front of your restaurant for
five consecutive days make sure people
see you understand your commitment to
quality it'll make a difference
hopefully the newspaper pick it up with
a photo they will they already did last
year when I was with the partner I was
the operational one so it'll be bad so
look I think the the my version of that
which is all right and definitely the
way I grew up is I want you to go to
Instagram and type in Wildwood New
Jersey and search it and see the nine
trending pictures on Instagram right now
and I want you to either DM or comment
the individuals that are there because
usually if they're one of the nine most
popular they're the people that
are over indexing have the biggest
audience and I want you to one-on-one
engage with them at scale and then and
then really win your REIT awk about
hashtags on Instagram yeah but I think
that there's a big white space to search
by location and engage with the people
in that location I think you could
basically pull eyes and bodies into your
restaurant by engaging virtually through
people that are putting up content
virtually especially these three months
and you could do with hand-to-hand
combat digitally Wow
okay I'm not new to the internet game -
like I do stuff those well Goodwin it's
not a fad the shit's real well thank you
very again I appreciate yeah all right
good guy look at the Jersey Flay I love
you that was some East Coast [ __ ] right
there for everybody who's watching let's
get another call talk to me about your
journey on unsocial are you doing your
Twitter is your team it's okay I just
want to know we started doing it and
honestly you know in our profession yeah
we're in a bar business
yes hospitality yes we're not in a
social media I get it I get it so we've
gone through four or five different
agencies understood and found a process
extremely frustrating understood so
we've brought it in-house we've taken it
out a sweater in have taken a nap in
house we've never parked it in a place
where I can actually feel good about it
understood are you pop tarted in my
voice as well are you are you just
adamantly against doing it yourself is
it hard it doesn't come natural no it's
that I travel 40 weeks a year I shoot 12
hours a day and it's just it's hard to
allocate the time to do it on the other
hand you'll tell me John you're crazy
not to allocate and I'm also going to
tell what you tell the other business
owners right in a 20-17 environment with
you know what's ironic is you are so
built for it it's scary but I'm gonna
bargain you're you're in a social media
know it's funny no I've never perfected
it you know what you are you're
communicator
you're a bar guy who happens to be a
phenomenal communicator it's why you
spoke in the first place which led to
the TV show in the first place I
genuinely believe in the same way that
you've taught operators the cadence of
doing the right thing that if you
actually bit you know you bit the bullet
and you did it for a week or two you
would it would come so unbelievable
natural based on your DNA hmm I really
mean it and just doing a casual intimate
sense be you in the moment I don't know
tell people go [ __ ] themselves I'm
whatever you know whatever whatever like
look you can't you can't lose and I
think once you actually taste it for
real mm-hmm
they'll come as natural to you as it
came to me because guess what what was
32 years old wasn't like I grew up with
this [ __ ] I was on a computer five
minutes in my entire life until I was 20
like it's about communication and you've
got that pouring out of your [ __ ]
eyes well I'm under personally you've
sinned spired me well thank you I'm
gonna pick this up tomorrow and start
doing this and I got another pump so so
you are pumped you are so happy with me
right now he is he's been pushing me to
do this for long I'm gonna kill it on
Twitter you're gonna kill you're gonna
kill it it's interesting how I can be
comfortable in front of 90 million
Americans I see they but that phone
environment I'm not again you know this
right we're great at our lanes but we
know that we're not as comfortable in
other lanes I just know that it's the
context of it because your ability in it
is going to dominate you're going to
find yourself on Wi-Fi on the plane
engaging on Twitter left and right me
asking you quiet you should have been
engaged in Twitter and Facebook yes and
I type in I get as many as I can you
killing that I'm not doing is I'm not
using my camera very often and I'm not
going live car you don't worry about
live from it you know where you can
crush I would die and bunch of people
watching would die to follow this as
you're walking through the airport you
see a restaurant front facing you take a
picture and you leave your two cents you
may feel with love that that's good idea
great coloring on the letter [ __ ]
signage got it
yeah your great idea definitely content
everywhere listen I I'm going to be a
dick all day long and critique people
can you imagine and on the flip side you
know the way the show's edited I think
you can you can create a second path
which is unsocial maybe you go the path
of like showing things that you think
are done well because first of all let's
think about this you're going through
you're walking through New York City you
see something you think as well you take
a picture you go this is extremely well
executed when you when that bar sees
that they share it this that you see
where I'm going
I do yeah oh yeah it's brilliant well
who's coming in now
Kevin from Chicago let's see what Kevin
from Chicago I'm fired up now yawn I
think you're gonna die on a fart I think
it hit me up in like four months ago
o'clock I should have done it you know
Kevin hello Kevin this is Gary Vee and
your new askgaryvee show Gary my man how
are you
amazing how are you good bro you're on
with John can you say hello hey John
what's going on hey buddy how are you
can be yours chillin Enoch yeah man we
wake you up you smoke like that blonds
like what's going on here have you chill
bro I'm trying my best not to freak out
right now okay God okay I got it
what's your question alright so my
brother's 13th birthday is coming up and
July okay I was wondering if you had any
ideas like what kind of gift to give him
that would be like very good for his
life and life changing okay so what's
the story at 13 right now I loves
basketball starting to go through
puberty voice changing is dizzy on deck
there Z on Instagram no he's not he's on
snapchat they love snapchat so I have an
idea for a 13th birthday I think you
should have them create an Instagram
account and my friend here dunk who has
two million followers in the basketball
space 2.2 million is going to give them
a shout out and send people his way
that's great he'll [ __ ] his pants and
week who's favorite players and create a
whole community Rashad it's better than
that he'll get like I will get like
4,000 followers on Instagram and not
know what to do with himself
Kevin that's a huge freakout it's a done
deal email me a Gary at vaynermedia dunk
so these things for like $50,000 I just
gave you $50,000 Kevin appreciate it
thank you doc you're welcome
he's very excited about it and Kevin
thanks for calling we just made a 13
year olds life I hope Kevin if you're if
you're a Gary at vaynermedia comp dunk
you're the best I know you are cuz
you're the best
yeah good dude while Andy is getting
another call what uh what in your career
growing
what was the best run organization that
you worked in before you went on to the
next part what was the place where you
like really learned how to do you a lot
of place I'm sure you learn how not to
do it
but where was a place that really who
was a great operator what was a great
experience for you early on yeah you
know it wasn't somebody I worked for was
somebody worked with okay and you'd be
surprised by the answer and it's going
back a number of years but Disney that's
not surprising to me anytime Gettys come
on people here to employ orientation I
mean Disney you don't wear uniforms you
wear costumes you don't work at a
station you work on a stage every door
is a stage order to friend the house to
the back of the house you never break
character their depth of training was
incredible even a janitor the guy who
sweeps yeah they knew that he would get
more questions than anyone so he knew
everything the interest even for their
depth of training and submission you
worked with hell under what context what
was the story back then is I'm not
permitted the public understood for
signs of school no worries we worked
with them on that's awesome sounds
really cool and what about what about
early on uh what brought you into the
industry just like literally just making
two bucks an hour like you're just like
that's how you got into politics believe
in I don't want the university then we
started pending bar but I had two loves
politics and cultural anthropology which
you'll find interesting question so I
love the study of primates and animal
societies which are just like us so I've
learned to analyze people my crew calls
it dr. John but I can analyze somebody
in seconds just their landing point
defines everything 100% you know do you
land in a selfish interest do you land
and gracious interest where do you land
because where your land is truly you
then you try to fix it after that that's
right so it's all very primal
you know that's helped me a lot in my
other careers clearly I mean I brought
up earlier even through the editing
process of the television show it was
interesting and obvious to me that you
created on eacute what I would call EQ
emotional intelligence other people
behavior like I've got a very good read
on everybody who I interact with very
quickly as well predicated on just it's
pretty basic if it comes natural to you
if you've learned it things of that
nature
you got something what's the problem
over here no no slow so wherever you
guys
Glanville California okay let's see what
Glenn's got for us John Glenn you're on
the askgaryvee show
oh this is crazy
it's okay house California oh it's
looking amazing see the runaround me
afraid what's your question so um all
right well perfect ours please say hello
to John T
hey I don't hey guys does that how you
doing man
doing great so um I do a YouTube channel
I have about 24 k subscribers I have
about a 50 Cal my facebook going pretty
well um only been doing it for a year
and a half it's called belief in
fatherhood bw2 shout it out but anyway
um I just did a deal with Apple Apple
was like hey I love your picture I love
this picture that you use on Instagram
they be double freaking user for our
campaign worldwide so literally there
are 90 billboard sized pictures of my
son
around the world that's already trying
to figure out yeah it's great so I know
that this is just like a it's a cool
thing you know it's going to happen but
I know because then when you give me
anything
besides the money that we got off top
you know right which is cool but I'm
trying to figure out how to leverage
this opportunity into something bigger
and so put some more brands you not I'm
saying I dunno I dunno you guess where
he is where no in other words you can
have some type of an online activity
that's interactive where you could guess
where he is locate him and something
along those kind of lines to create
engagement so bed saw yeah I mean so
what real quick how old the child he's
four so in the door boy every window and
I mean so it's interesting so you so one
more time because I want to make sure I
heard this right Apple's Apple obviously
licensed the image from you that they
saw online through through rep you
through Facebook or Instagram just I
want to get all the details to Graham
okay you're freaking hashtag only thing
I ever has been wild uh and they bought
the rights to the photo obviously and
they're using it in how many billboards
and how many markets I want to hear it
one more time 90 different billboards
across
the world around the world and so you're
saying yourself okay
my four-year-old son is on ninety
billboards I took you took the photo I
took the photo and you're thinking about
how do i leverage this opportunity right
right in keep in mind like though I have
very low numbers like you know 24 KS and
a lot you know if I put up a video for
ad on Facebook it gets two or three
million views in understand so I can I
can create very heartfelt stuff for the
black community for church folk and
stuff like that but I'm trying to figure
out how to present this to brand better
because I have all these working
relationships but I can't get like you
know real money in understand of course
I know because brands oftentimes are
paying for distribution and are
commoditizing out creative and you're
playing in a creative world and
obviously you've shown some distribution
capabilities let's take it a step back
what what bucket do you want to put this
talent into like what do you want to
build do you want to build an agency do
you want to build a product I think one
of the things that back to the way you
know the reason John's shaking his head
now these are practical questions I
think but the model of I want to get
brands to pay me more for branded posts
on social networks is fine and I think
is an emerging Lee massive market but
you're also at the vulnerability of the
platforms the Terms of Service changing
the market behaviors I think the
question becomes what what do you want
to do with your creative talents are
trying to build a service business i
trill trying to build a product business
I trying to go to personal brand where
you gather advocacy business that's
right like a cookie so I'm doing that's
right right where do you want to take it
I think you have to make those decisions
on weird right no go ahead
yeah so I want to be a you know the
thought leader on parenting five years
from now everything I do with these
vlogs and these videos only shows my
validity and how I can speak on these
topics as a father from the father
perspective and as a husband so ok six
seven years from now and CNN is having
some issues with parenting they can
bring in the talk to me about it I
understand but in the short term I need
to make financial I need to making a
month you understand I thought well of
course I do well advocacy and money
don't always travel hand-in-hand
together so you know I know from one and
this is just my view if you want to
monetize this then you know you need
money for charity no money no charity so
you start with the monetization and then
you build to the advocacy I don't think
it's the other way around would you
agree gir yes but I think what he's
asking is a little bit it's a little bit
interesting what he's up to so so real
quick you've been able to make some
money from brands on creating content on
your personal profiles yes sir how much
like $500 a post like that kind of
numbers nine nine hundred um yeah none
do you know this phenomenon there's like
we believe that it's a two to three
billion dollar market of people with
large social network accounts mainly on
Instagram and Facebook where brands will
pay them for you know in essence
commercials they're post you know
advertorial yes that's the way we grew
up as a Western I'm sure I'm sure so I
look I think there's a I give there's a
couple ways to do this I've got a very
rogue answer for you are you selling are
you trying to make this your full-time
living do you have a job currently as
well
I can't from here pop I'm trying to get
out of hip-hop I'm moving to our
fatherland because it understood know
you say you care for me about do you
have a job right now where are you
trying to live your life no okay I'm
gonna throw you for a curve how old are
you
I'm 32 so when you become the person
that the big media companies in six or
seven years call for fatherhood in your
genre things of that nature is your plan
to get a million dollar book advance to
get paid $40,000 to give speeches are
you looking to older and what okay I
would tell you that I think you should
get a job and I think you should go
right I think you should get a job for
somebody who's a personal brand I think
you look under the hood
the great advantage the thing that
allowed John and I to sit here today and
have all these people watching and
listening is we did the thing for
decades before we talked about the thing
yeah I believe that if you got a
forty-five thousand and eighty thousand
a ninth I'm not going to speak to your
finances but I believe if you work the
nine to six nine two seven to be the
social media guide for any personal
brand whether it's in your genre or not
and will probably won't be in your genre
an athlete an actress a politician if
you could see somebody I'm a big fan
of working for somebody who's doing the
thing that you want to do you get to see
everything under the hood and I would
love to see you get pay your bills and
learn the do's and the don'ts and then
use that platform to build yourself up
I'm a very big advocate of the advice
that I'm giving and let me be clear I
know it's taking a step backwards to
take two steps forward a lot more fun to
kind of sell your $900 post here your
$800 post there but I genuinely believe
that a year or two of that work could
become disproportional powerful because
what you're going to do is I love when I
see what some does or he sees what I do
and then you work it on your account
like it's incredible to like see the
do's and don'ts and I think there's a
way for you to possibly get that job and
then build off of that
and that's just one way to go about it
by the way the other way is to keep
scrapping you just sorry you have to say
something as a father of a 28 year old
I'm just not sure you're an authority of
being a father when you have a
four-year-old Tommy Wednesday but this
tip this is a thing like people people
want they see me as successful because
they see how well-behaved my children
are but they don't realize that I still
have to raise a thirty-year-old you
notice in life you have to get to 30 in
order for me to be considered a success
so I'm kind of in a weird position where
people want to see what it's like to be
proof that fatherhood is even something
that they want because they don't
believe in it because they're you know
something they all have their fathers
around so all I am is cool I feel that
success you through I think I think
John's right I think you're right right
which is why I created that whole genre
of document don't you know document
don't create all these people faking it
saying I'm a great father instead of
look cute you know crew I've been really
pushing my audience on to like hey
faking that you're an expert at bars
because you've worked in one for a year
and you want to be known as that because
it sounds cool or it seems like you make
money that way is fine you're going to
trick a couple of losers winners are
going to look at you as a winning I'll
tell you in a minute
you jumped in right away and said wait a
my bro your kids for but when I think
he's doing and and and culturally he's
painting about her that's right he's
like I have a four year old and that's
where I'm at now so listen I'd listen I
think
you've got two options a couple of
options you've got probably way more
than that I think the thing that you can
do is deploy massive patience produce
far more content that you're producing
now you know hustled more produce tons
of content and build a very slow burn
for 70 years
I did five episodes a day of Wine
Library TV in 2006 for I don't know
about four years before I kind of like
meant a little something for years every
day you know putting out that show daily
five days a week you know I think a lot
of you in my audience know a lot of you
just discovered me in January been
putting out content on the internet
every single day for a decade for a
decade at scale successfully so I think
I think you either deploy patience and
make your 900 here your 100 here your
500 year one month is four thousand you
feel like you got it the next month that
goes to 80 bucks you like what the [ __ ]
or you take the route that I painted
first which is do you go and get a job
as a social media content person for a
very famous athlete or actor or actress
so you could see it at a higher plane so
you see what it tastes like at the
$10,000 post at the hundred thousand
dollar speaking engagement so that
you're like okay that's what it takes to
get there got it or you do both got it
it's like there's the same advice I
would give to somebody who asked that
question about the bar business I
believe you may go to work for the best
one you can find around that you know
work for an example and learn from that
example same deal
well I appreciate you coming back a lot
too you keep us under editor thank you
John you know it's interesting right
like it's fun for me to hear you say
that right now because literally I mean
I think that's generally what attracted
why I mean [ __ ] to watch for hours I was
watching around Thanksgiving Christmas
do I fell they were always doing
marathons watching my family like let's
all watch this like it was you know it's
just it's unbelievable how if people
deployed patience they could get what
they want they just don't want to they
want passive income quick well there is
no quick took you long no to monetize
your work no nobody's got quick nobody's
Beyonce has been dancing [ __ ] sing
and she's like for like every athlete
outside of the super freaks like 88% of
them it's the heart and by the way
there's the four hundred best football
baseball basketball players on natural
talent are
in the league because they didn't work
hard enough well you don't become a
household name for no reason I believe
that to almost no case I'm a big mistake
ladies a lifetime to get to that point
and it is a challenge and hard work okay
listen I can perhaps this 100% I can
work really really hard at baseball like
real hard 18 hours a day what is going
to happen like there's a little
self-awareness in it so I love business
and entrepreneurship it gives everybody
a little bit more of a chance it's not a
physical attribute makes a mental one
but one more last one which is who's
this Oh Glenn it no Chandler Chandler
Parsons
okay right person hello this is Chandler
Chandler is Gary be on your ass and you
are on the askgaryvee show
hey how are you doing doing really well
please say hello to my phenomenal gas
John hey John what's up man how are you
good man how are you I'm doing well I
got to tell you guys you're both idols
of mine so this is all sounds like
you're a very smart man yes obviously
man great claim clearly you are a winner
that depends on whether you talk about
whether you were a winner
ha okay how can we help you with yeah so
I run a barbecue restaurant in Kentucky
and you guys are marketing geniuses both
of you um so just you know what advice
do you have for small guys like me you
know competing with the big guys out
there John before you answer that
Chandler can you give us a little more
context how many years what kind of
revenue like give us something to give
you a real egg we could give real good
answer for that question but here we are
right let's go let's go a little further
give us a little more context how long
you open you have to do it in sales sure
so we started as a food tent a couple
years - work your way up to a gas
station after that we actually just
closed that location open our next
location which is a real location now so
yeah we'll do about a million dollars in
sales are you yeah so you know we're
just we've done a lot of social media
stuff to this point but you know it
seems like I don't know I have to have
we hit a plateau yeah no time like we're
we're getting ready to bring a video guy
on full-time we showcase barbecue show
on YouTube how you feel about your
location our new location is really
strong um but you know I'm one of those
guys like what we're doing now is plenty
to make enough money the problem is that
we're just like I always want more you
know what I mean I'm always trying to
get better I don't wanna get complacent
I really feel like we just hit what so
because I buy okay what's your traffic
count the road we're on you probably
15,000 or so okay so you're on a road
that we qualify for a national franchise
so he's got some good potential
they love that acrylic on that road you
know I wanna say something that I think
Gary's gonna agree with me you know
we're not in the in the content business
we're not in a restaurant business
you're not in a barbecue business we're
all in the business of creating
reactions when it creates a reaction it
works doesn't it when it creates no one
it doesn't work so the post isn't a
product the reaction is the product the
post is the vehicle to you barbecue
isn't a product barbecue is a vehicle
the product is a reaction our people
reacting well are they sitting up when
the food hits the table their feet
tapping to the music you're playing
how are you guests reacting to what
you're doing yeah everything reaction
wise has been fantastic you know they're
all my mom's recipes all homemade we
like to joke she was farm-to-table
before was hip you know she grew up on a
farm in South Georgia but yeah I mean
people loved the food so you had a
father he's online
yeah yes sir yeah you have a story in a
most powerful asset to marketing
particularly to Millennials these days
is to have a story is that story online
that people know that story your
mother's recipe are you creating
curiosity online in a marketplace to try
your mom's recipes
I think we're I'm from the under guy
that doesn't marketing I'm probably
dropping the ball on not really
hammering home the mom side of it not
not only that you're not hammering home
[ __ ] because you haven't posted an
Instagram in four days uh-uh you are you
are right about that I'm aware and so to
me you hit you know hitting a plateau
from a marketing standpoint like you as
somebody who's got such a great piece of
seafood for Instagram like you've been
reaving a gift I'm working with people
that have concrete come
I like like fencing like doorknobs you
have barbecue food in Kentucky like you
should be pressing four times a day on
Instagram right and and and you're not
so for me you haven't tapped out
anything you haven't even started but
it's even more than that right I'd be
posting pictures of the smoker the
products smoking the raw product you
know making real quality statements in
what you're doing you've got to create
curiosity so people want to want to the
front door and taste it and Channel when
you have a baby that ridiculously cute
sitting next to you and working on the
business like this is you so you wait a
minute you've got barbecue in Kentucky
which allows you to speak about a lot of
things like sports and other things it
doesn't have to always be about the food
right you could talk about the
basketball team and things of that
nature the recruiting so you think
people like the counters are like that
brother are you if you literally post
and use the hashtag whoever Kentucky
recruited and I promise you five of them
are Superstars and you use their hashtag
of those five I promise you that people
going to discover that because they're
clicking that hashtag Kentucky best
prime basketball it's religion so yeah I
already do like when I look at your
Instagram and and great job I Andy here
like pulling up your stuff like we
haven't even begun here right and we're
going to one day just on the beans one
day just on the coleslaw like one day
just on the beans like for variety for
the content just on the being art of
being good I mean that's so easy to do
to on your hundred-percent right because
it's all made from scratch so the
essence of making stuff from scratch is
a story so you can see the path there
yeah I mean there's best touching beans
on the plant dude I love beans so I got
a something I'm looking at your
retaining them right now and we'll slice
ours
and there's a bottom left picture which
I got to tell you guys is one who takes
professional food pictures that picture
sucks and the reason why is you're
showing little unimportant things you
got to come in on the meat you got to
show the juiciness to thickness of the
job here on this one right like what is
that that's a hush puppy right but
you're getting closer to the product you
can see the crisp the flavor try to make
these pressures a little closer try to
get people to connect those are okay
well that's almost a look at that is
gross there you
that's some [ __ ] right there moving from
US Air Force is there a base nearby I
know not here and this post on May 14th
the one that said happy Mother's Day
right you know you've got the Mother's
Day hashtag but there's no other
hashtags that you used right you could
have read so like you got to get into
best practices too and remember right
you Colding that means you know me and I
always say watch what I'm doing not what
I what I'm saying and like you know that
I'm treating my Instagram very
differently than you're treating your
Instagram right right yeah
I guess I guess I just has a double down
on I mean I'm not I guess for our market
I'm just not believing in Instagram but
that's probably don't so I mean we do a
ton of Facebook advertising and really
going to that but yeah I know it look
look it's not about being dumb or not or
it being dumb or not it's it's it's
mapping your output to your ambition you
machine something really about that well
explain you would seen something
incredible most people will never build
a business that does a million dollar
years in revenue right and I've known a
million 1 million plus a god bless right
to me me yeah me I just heard from you
you open this and let's rewind it that
said you're still hungry and like yeah
yeah I'm net listen you got a little one
at home I'm not telling you how to do
your work-life balance
I'm not telling you that you do you
here's what I can tell you by looking at
your Facebook and YouTube and Instagram
in a 20-18 environment around food
culture that is completely being
dominated by consumption online I don't
think your actions are speaking to you
being hungry okay so what I I know your
answers always do everything right yes
to everything but you know obviously
Instagram yes what are the two other
things I can do in 2017 to set us up
right for 2018 so again I think you know
watch what I do and and not what I say I
think you should be bright I think you
should literally get an intern from a
local high school or college if you
can't afford it or if you can't afford
it or you have a relative I think they
should literally film you every single
day and you should put out a piece of
content for third you know three minutes
seven minute 19 minute video on a date
day basis Lyle's barbecue day-to-day
every single day from those videos I
think you should do 4 posts on Instagram
7 on Twitter 5 on Facebook and I think
you should start a barbecue podcast
Kentucky barbecue podcast and put out a
show once a week on audio above and
beyond wrecking everyday and turning
care of your little guy if you're as
hungry as you [ __ ] say you are but if
you were then you would have posted up
in that Ford a gap wouldn't exist I
stood by or the phone I'm John I'm
empathetic he's the jailers deemed that
you know that's not as important
Facebook ads are working better in
January you know it's fun to talk to you
so you know my spiel would you like fine
that's doing better now but it's also
because you're not doing your ram well
right now absolutely you're you're right
about that we we just need to go back to
doing some homework and and get into
practicing you're under percent right I
want to add one thing if I can for you
you know you can increase your guest
frequency by one visit a month that's a
12 to 15 percent increase in revenue
right one visit more per month is 12 to
15 percent you need to work on that as
well so you need to have the frequency
programs in place you need to have
programs to get people to come midweek
back on weekends people have a
propensity to come on weekends to come
back midweek you need to work this in a
more immediacy type of a way you've got
to increase frequency as well especially
in a market like yours we can only get
too many so many new customers you got a
lot of barbeque in your area sure yeah
so that's really so sometimes it isn't a
question of adding more customers
sometimes it's a question of adding more
customers and more frequency and that's
the combo that together will make you
much more success there's also the
insight so let me ask you it fast yeah
really great but in restaurant business
you know pricing is key now and I know
like with us being a fast casual
restaurant Jon where do you think the
price point needs to be average ticket
wise because I I'm out of the belief
that we're cuz we make everything from
scratch were priced just a little bit
higher and you know we do a lot to try
to differentiate ourselves with
marketing and and telling stories on
Facebook and things but we're gonna have
to do better obviously it sounds like
but what price point do you think and
does that play into it at all well let's
say you selling a steak
for a half the price of somebody else
and somebody conducting and says your
steak is too expensive they're not
Saylor it's too expensive because they
pay twice the price for a steak
someplace else they're telling you your
steak is not worth the price so I don't
think you should ever lower your price
you need to make the statements to
provide the value commence revert that
price so are you saying the things
recipes spec our best ribs are the best
in the world the media sit falls off the
bone you got you don't have an absolute
value issue you have a value perception
issue and there's a difference between
perceived value and absolute value
sounds like your I wouldn't know we
price our I rebuild my value statements
and with interesting about that advice
is there was something in the way that
you were communicating about Facebook
versus Instagram I would highly
recommend you think about branding
versus sales to many people when they're
right it's it's you know - well yeah it
you know that's the case yeah I could
just tell that you're smart enough man
to know a shitload of eyeballs are on
Instagram right yeah
so you know no good no I was going to
say they are I guess I'm just I don't
know I'm doing that stupid thing where
people like justify that it's not
happening in their area or but it's
happening everywhere yeah this whole
notion that the ran through your monitor
that nobody in [ __ ] Lexington
Kentucky is on Instagram is ludicrous
you know honestly right what you're
doing is you're assuming an excuse which
is worser than making an excuse in and
of itself yeah I mean you don't assume
anything until you know it that's what's
exciting about this environment and the
things that you're doing is you can test
all of these and it's not only what you
do is how you do it as Gary's saying to
make it war work effectively but don't
make the excuse out of the gate because
then you're going to discount your
initiative in your effort before you
start it's so it's interesting here I
believe so much in driving people to you
if you've got quality the cost of
acquisition is something that is
fascinating to me so for example we're
about to do something at Wine Library my
family business we have a huge gourmet
department I want to continue to build
it right and we're about to create
something called free food Friday like
we're gonna give away a fuckload of free
food like just like my know show up
between this three hours and we're going
to give you a 20
gift certificate and the truth is the
cost of acquisition for us that $20
because we know our business is so much
better than a lot of other pieces that
we can make that ry+ in a two or three
year window
I am fastened along and I make that
lease for him that is exactly the same
thing on a different way if you buy a
guess through traditional media the cost
of that guest is typically forty to
eighty dollars bingo
if you so let's say your rib dinner cost
you five dollars food costs there is the
potato the platter the whole thing I
would give out a hundred coupons for a
free rib dinner to people that have
never been there before no restrictions
so now Gary walks up to the front door
with a coupon I got a coupon for a free
rib dinner never been here before come
on in first of all I don't pay till they
come second I'm paying four dollars and
sixty-five cents not forty to sixty
dollars per each customer and then
here's something that nobody else will
tell you if somebody goes to a
restaurant for the first time and has a
flawless experience the statistical
likelihood of them doing a second visit
is about forty percent they come here I
believe that InDesign and have flawless
experience the statistical likelihood of
a third visit is still about 42% the
third time they come the statistical
likelihood of a fourth visit is over 70%
so well I've got a market to three
visits not one visit one from rib dinner
if you sit him down put a red napkin on
a table not a white one identify them as
a first-time customer connect with them
and work to get them back a second time
in the third time once they're there the
third time you own them mostly the red
napkin thing is genius always because
you know the fast-casual environment
we're not hitting that table money but
let me give you forget napkin it's
riddle chair letting my detail that good
okay so you put a red napkin at the
table Gary sits down he's eating dinner
now he's getting his free rib dinner
orders water cost of nothing I know here
at first time customer because he's got
a red napkin when he's leaving a manager
comes to the table writes on the back of
the business card five dollars off
chicken did you like the ribs love them
you gotta try my chicken come in for the
chicken now I'm prompting a second visit
not with a printed right hand
card now he comes in a second visit
drops the business card on the table
everybody knows this is a second visit
because red napkin was the first visit
second visit Emil you go if you say so
how is the chicken it was fricking great
are you folk totally stuffed man next
time you got to try my cheesecake peas
free piece of cheesecake now three
visits Ripley I'll be fine a piece of
cheese I thought of peanuts not labor
cheesecake I was like that's [ __ ]
brilliant and the rib didn't cleanse me
$5 the chicken will wash out decimated
discounts right the cheesecake is a
drought of 35 for about six hours you
got three visits out of them with a 70%
likelihood of a fourth that's the way
your market a restaurant with that more
walnut that is that is that is that is
huge right that's why you threw the bet
let me listen let me give you one more
for the road mr. Geary was a very
interesting thing that John said because
I grew up in that environment too and
John's from the traditional marketing
world that we grew up in from pulling
from his world notice how he said first
time customer I'll give it to you
because the traditional retail and bar
thing is like look it works but like
you've already got somebody in the
funnel the cost of acquisition for a new
buddy is very very very powerful I used
to do that too but it was tricky right
because now some of your old time
customers may see that and they've got
that angst of wait a minute why am I
being not treated that way as a loyal
customer
you just want new people and it's always
been a put ass friction for us right in
the reach right now I just want to
Instagram right I tucked in Lexington
Kentucky
got it yes sir I'm looking at nine posts
right now that are top posts and ungodly
amounts unlimited amounts of people's
posts that are from Lexington Kentucky I
went down all the way down and that's
from 48 minutes ago 40 pictures down 48
minutes ago thousands of people are
posting right now on Instagram from
Lexington Kentucky I go to the top nine
post I click the middle one it's a nice
little cute couple right they got 298
likes Abby she's got she's from
somewhere she's part of a sorority it
looks like just 2387 followers there's a
triple dot in
operate corner on Instagram I hit it and
let me send her a message I send her a
message a b c or lexington we love being
part of lexington here's a $20 off
coupon $10 off coupon free chicken only
she sees it you're grabbing somebody who
has a big social media profile you've
not heard any of your loyal customers
like me and John had to back in the day
she comes and she posts a picture of the
food and creates word-of-mouth now that
five dollar acquisition created no
friction two loyal customers and because
she's now media she amplifies it and
you're getting an eighty five hundred
four thousand dollar media amplification
against your five [ __ ] dollars and
last one thing don't discount people get
addicted to discounts they don't get
addicted to free that's right so yeah I
know that's the one thing we probably
done right that we've never wavered on
was discounts I mean that you know
cheapen the product for sure well guys I
appreciate this and I just want to say
one thing you know when I separated from
the Air Force three years ago now I
watched a ton of our rescue and I
watched a ton of Gary's content and you
guys in the content you put out really
helped me built this business from
literally we were a tent on the side of
the road to now we have our brick and
mortar business with very little bet on
it and that's something you guys helped
seal it so I am eternally grateful and
if you're ever in Lexington first rack
of ribs on me and no red napkin needed
and and and and all end would thank you
what for what you've done for this
amazing country that is created a
framework for us to be all able to do
this that's right all right and if
anybody out there YouTube loves barbecue
company check us out love a good plug at
the end John this was such a pleasure my
friend tore this thing I really enjoyed
again yeah we should definitely do this
again now it's country watching me the
next few days when I go on are you on
this are you going to be on I'm going to
do what you advised me to do also I
remember say I am the neck I'm good I
focus on working on this in connecting
brainer
I want you to take a peek give me good
advice mix well the best part is the
vaynernation
tens of thousands of people are about to
bother you is a piece of cake for me I'm
dressed on the guest gets to ask the
question of the day so yep you're going
to get thousands of answers on YouTube
and Facebook what question do you want
to ask them a selfish consumer insights
one for you a general one something
that's funny to you what question of the
day do you have to take us out you know
I have a rescue tour that starts on July
10th and going 27 cities in six weeks to
teach small business people how to make
I love it and it's my passion it's a
three and a half hour program means the
world to me okay I want to hear from
everyone what is the most important
thing that I could teach them to
increase their revenues improve their
business I think I know what it is but
I'd love to hear it from them again
what is most important to you because
that's what I want to do I appreciate it
my friend you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering them
[Music]